block numero 12 indovinate qual è il mio
gatto preferito sono hanno preso tutto
da quel quasi stadi mettendo la ragazza
anche se tu rimani un mobile ti prego e
poi magari eletto oggi però non bisogna
pensare alla kakà oggi non si pensa
nessun problema oggi si fa musica
valentina assaggiato in tutta la tua
vita sembrarci per chi non lo sapesse è
un mix tra l'anci e la cosa che si fa
tradizionalmente nei paesi anglofoni
anni fa beh con salmone philadelphia
se lui è l'avvocato io sono il giudice o
un compito più importante la ventina a
creare la canzone del natale poterla
sparare nelle vostre camere dopo la
facciamo proprio un video ufficiale
non ci credo più io a quest anno fa
delle canzoni e non
è permesso all'insalata sopra la porta
no 6
ma dov'è il problema l'unica cosa che mi
interessa che per il 10 sta passando un
grande grande valentina viaggio in
francia
mamma mia non per quelli che fa partire
sono buonissimi non è mai mangiato
minuto
vestita allora no ragazzi per cucinare
in queste condizioni i ragazzi in questo
momento vorrei che questo coltello non
fosse che il dr
un pezzo di musica contemporanea su un
ipad
ciao ragazzi voi che avete bisogno di
studi di registrazione ipad
avremo il risultato la fine grazie a
tali laica poi sarà tremenda sono stufa
di bigliettoni non è che pazzo farà
pagare questa persona che chiama
d'accordo su qualcosa abitative non mi
vedo già un impedimento ma ragazzi
questi c'è potrà usarli come corpo
contundente da lanciare già ma non è
vero
con questo lo sai che ci si fa dei sassi
ci hanno presi sassi di me che teneva
rete sta vocato diseducativo da letto
pensano di partire un momento a cappella
letteralmente indietro non
professionista raffinatezza attacca
tutto quanto all ipad
il geniale
devo andare a rimediare ai fallimenti di
valentina con i suoi sassi mangiano
tutto ha detto dopo essermi fatto sette
giri del supermercato vanno bene che si
molli la mafia e salmone affumicato
sopra io vorrei metterci in questa
bellissima rosellina di scanu ma il suo
avvocato molle però malamente fano
attentamente e poi voglio farla mia
traccia tratto certo tutti voi dovrete
fare una traccia però intanto devo
creare una base la crei addirittura la
base no aggiungerò i loop del capitolo
si è preso una canzone fatta mangerò
anche la nonna non mangerò versilia si
parli di questa ricercatezza di
terminologica bommel ottenute notte
un'idea così geniale e un po deciso di
ispirarmi un pochino a quella che la
musica pop però mantenendola un pochino
più nell'indie perché comunque andando
tanto di moda per fortuna il natale è un
insieme di termini nuovi all'interno
delle festività del resto a dicembre
sono cose delle quali nessuno parla
allucinato i tra un'ora facendo un lungo
percorso di ricerca può ripetere che il
gene al microfono ma dato che le forze
dell'ordine sono qua sotto renderla vi
servivano dei suoni muoverà mente grazie
di cuore per tutto quello che fa per noi
per il mondo dal blog max è tutta brava
la finalmente gli hai fatto io voglio
saggia questo ma crudo in meno male che
secoli
della famiglia al fumo ma comunque per
nicolò 21 formale ha mai fatto che poi
cresci come insomma ok luglio schierano
col super non malissimo come stanno
andando le prove liberta nel mio momento
topico prima stavo dal fondo trattavo
ripetendo in testa più un buon
capolavoro ragazzi con un appello alla
nazione al mondo
tu ti senti colato strofa non sono un po
indietro con lavoro devo dire senza
l'ansia da prestazione
vuoi fare qualcosa di buono si in bocca
al lupo gabriele sono nella mente
dell'artista
io non ho neanche la canzone sbrigati ce
l'ha già
c'è una cosa che desidero per tutti voi
mi manca che cosa devi però per enrico
cento mentre cucini prepari un blush
pazzesco unibas king cercando qualcosa
di molto profondo e concettuale
valentina riuscita a terminare
imbarazzante cioè la strofa dirò di più
sulla base di ave maria in car bronzo a
mangiare sedesse dove stare
napoli quanti sono mi sorge sa tutto e
barabba ragazzi questo pezzo a cui sto
lavorando è la rivisitazione di una
canzone di natale che credo potrebbe
veramente lanciare la mia carriera da
scrittrice non so se più quella la
scrittrice quella da cantante devo dire
che forse potrei provare ad entrare a
dream it con questo pezzo se faranno una
seconda edizione
voglio dire vedo che conosco il giudice
però barba del genere non mi fanno
passare sono degli stolti questo potete
farla così sto lavorando a qualcosa di
molto forte e spero che possa smuovere
gli animi delle persone
seduto al telefono merda esatto se molto
alte lo rimando di provare non su man
davanti proprio invece di cantare sulla
coppole del in questo natale ed è pure
un po farvi sentire crik crok a cosa e
come sempre è mai parlato andava bene si
è parlato perfetto dire lo stava mica
cantando ha fatto la scelta più saggia
di molti hanno deciso di cantare le mie
strofe per adesso parlano di un
desiderio qui intravedo proprio la
trasformazione che c'è di un uomo è un
po complesso come messaggio e spero che
arrivi forte potente quando non si sa
cosa dire il si aprono matera hai
lavorato al tuo progetto stanno parlando
a tutta la canzone ancora non pensato a
cosa dire ma credo che sarà
un'introduzione tutti voi a questa
esperienza la trasformazione di un uomo
il trasformista anche da io non so
quando dopo partì loro idea e non so un
cantante rap ha visto che sono un cane
di come parla stiamo registrando una
croce di guglielmo che è un cantante
prof
quindi avrò la base con la voce di cui
chiedo seguirà passo passo le sue note
il suo tono andrà alla grande è quella
di enrico e melodicamente la più
complessa probabilmente per tutte ma io
c'ho una voce da usignolo è come i piani
decorati come cazzo la faccio
mamma mia come ti vedo male di cuffia
sono nato pronto
dammi tutto quello che hai basta farmer
inviato il testo è bernie testo il mondo
del regno di significato effettivamente
lo tengo io perché tutti sfido confuso e
non so dove mettere i tigrotti sono
state ovviamente il microfono tranquillo
ma non è il grande hit che sono tutte i
ragazzi a prima incredibile il
ritornello le modulazioni prometto mi ha
ricordato mozart il rock disponibile su
tutte le piattaforme o accanto sbagliato
l'attacco madrid e sto passando tutta la
giornata a sentire la stamperia dico
sarà la colonna sonora dei miei peggiori
incubi sto lo spettro del produsse la
partita da scontare questo anzi fa carlo
di farmi riprendere fiato non ce la
faccio più semplice
io non pensavo di cantare così male cioè
ma tu hai scelto proprio melodicamente
la cosa piuttosto la canzone sodio che
ha detto c'è la moglie e belle a curarli
ave maria
ecco la sto facendo il palazzetto il
palazzetto mi salverà
bene
[Applauso]
scusa ma tu che tipo di pensare
pronunciate cantante emma questo sei
riuscito facciamo una canzone ma chi
cazzo la cantano concludo per molti per
peter ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video affamati raccomando
domani uscirà il videoclip della nostra
canzone lavorato giorno e notte di
domani alle 14 il video della canzone
domani ore domani
saluto con la mano e basta
[Risate]